I don't know what your process is but so
many of your songs so many of your
parody songs and so many of your your as
much of your best work revolves around
food have you noticed that yeah I mean
it almost looks like I've seen about it
today like you know instead much funnier
like my bologna you know I'm thinking
that there's must have been a period of
your life where you were just hungry and
a starving artist yeah yeah oh you're
doing is is coming up with songs about
food is that been a quick
yeah that's heard it more of an 80s
thing I got a lot of food song from the
80s and I kind of got away from that
right because I they put out a whole
food-related album and I think yeah I
kind of stuck in a writer I should move
on to something else right but you know
it really came out came in handy in the
80s because you know I needed food to
get inspired so I could write off my
grocery bills on my tax you know see
your early work inspired by food there
must have been another I don't know
technique that you use like when you
would sit down and watch someone's video
you know back in the day when they
actually showed video I remember that
and you would watch it how long did it
take you to take you a long time to
figure out how you were going to parody
that performer it varies a most most
often it takes a while because I'm not a
freestyle or I can't I don't think of
ideas usually spontaneously and I have
to really think I'll go what are the
hundred variations on the theme I could
do with this this song I remember what
the one time where I thought of a idea
immediately was for for fat the Michael
Jackson parody bad yeah I remember that
I was watching the world premiere of bad
on TV and he comes down I guess in the
subway right yeah yeah and and I just
you know I immediately had the Epiphany
like when they were coming through the
turnstile in the subway it's like what
if this guy like weighed 800 pounds are
you trying to get through the turnstile
no fat all right there I decide oh
that's what I'm gonna do
you